Speaker 1: . It's great to welcome back to
the program today, Dr. Orlock Kanojia, who's
a psychiatrist practicing in Boston, Massachusetts,
and on the faculty at Harvard Medical School,
also the co-founder of Healthy Gaymer, an
organization using meditation and advances
in neuroscience and coaching to help gamers
take back control of their lives.
It's great to have you back on today.
Speaker 6: Thanks a lot, David.
It's a pleasure to be here again.
Speaker 1: So what are you seeing generally
maybe to get us into the conversation about
what's going on with people's mental health
and psyche and sort of predisposition to what
is now starting to hopefully be an exit from
from the pandemic?
Speaker 6: Yes, that's a great question.
So during the pandemic, we saw an increase
in depressive symptoms.
So there was a paper by the Journal of the
American Medical Association which basically
found a three hundred percent worsening in
depression during the pandemic.
And so as people were sort of getting inclosed,
also like lower access to vitamin D and things
like that resulted in worsening depression.
The really fascinating thing is I'm seeing
something that I really haven't heard clinically
described, which I would call reintegration
anxiety, which is very unusual.
But basically people have been enclosed so
long and I see this a lot in the university
students that we work with that they're like
actually concerned about like they want to
reengage with the real world, but they feel
anxious that socially they've become rusty.
They're not sure that they're going to be
able to do in person school.
So it's really interesting because there's
almost some degree of fear about reintegrating
into the real world.
Speaker 1: Some of this I see in in a very
what seems more like just unknowns about the
data.
Right.
Which is OK, when I go to the grocery store
and I see people without a mask, now I'm imagining
that there is just a virus coming out of their
mouth.
Right.
It's because this this is what the idea that
was sort of ingrained in us before vaccination
and so on and so forth.
But you're saying this goes beyond just waiting
to understand and feel good about the science.
It's something above and beyond this.
Speaker 6: Yeah, absolutely.
So if we look at like our brains when we don't
use a particular circuit in our brain, it
rusts.
So if I speak two languages and I don't speak
one of the languages for a year, I get rusty.
Yep.
So what we find in covid is everyone is interacting
online.
So there are parts of our brain which make
us feel socially reassured, like the parts
of our brain which will interpret body language,
tone, facial expressions and things like that,
which on online interactions we don't really
get.
So now as people are starting to reintegrate
into society and like socially be active in
person, those rusty circuits of our brain
are causing us to like, not feel reassured.
And I'm seeing this bizarre spike in social
anxiety as people are reintegrating.
Yeah, and it's really strange.
There are people
Speaker 1: there are people I know which is
related, I think, to social anxiety who have
said, you know, I went to the grocery store
and they're back to full capacity.
I was wearing a mask, but some people weren't.
And I just almost had like a panic response.
Like, I'm just going to take my two items.
I've grabbed and not finished my shop and
I'm leaving.
Is that a sort of agoraphobia type response
that's taking place?
Speaker 6: I wouldn't quite call it agoraphobia,
because if we think about agoraphobia, it's
the it's usually like the inability to control
circumstances which causes you to retreat
into your home.
What I really think it is is almost what you
are saying.
We've been sort of conditioned to fear people
without masks.
Right.
We've been told there have been death tolls
and stories about refrigeration trucks filled
with bodies with covid.
There's a lot of information about these new
variants which are ripping through countries
that previously were doing pretty well.
So I think the people especially who have
taken that to heart and have been careful
are going to be the ones that will we've conditioned
ourselves to be afraid of that thing.
So it's almost like a conditioned response,
like a conditioned fear that now we have to
start undoing.
Speaker 1: I've told my audience that all
along I've followed CDC guidelines even when
I didn't really think I needed to be wearing
a mask on the bike path outdoors.
I did it because people around me were.
And it was sort of like a social calculation
that that I made.
And now as masks are coming off, I've said,
you know, I was just traveling.
And where I went, people weren't wearing masks
and grocery stores.
So I didn't either.
But then when I got back, I stick my head
into the grocery store.
I mostly see masks.
I put my mask on.
I have no medical reason why I'm doing that.
Right.
The CDC guidelines are I don't need that mask.
Is it in some way bad that I'm doing this
merely to just not stand out as the guy?
Not.
Wearing a mask, is there some some concerning
longer term impact of me behaving in that
way?
Speaker 6: Well, let's start by understanding
why you behave that way, which is because
your brain is wired to behave that way.
OK, so if we think about how do children learn
language, how do children learn body like
body movements?
And if we think about as our language evolves
over time, you know, we start to use new slang.
It's because our brain is literally wired
where communal animals is Homo sapiens.
And we look at what the other Homo sapiens
are doing and we are going to feel like doing
the same thing.
It's why peer pressure is a thing.
It's why fashion fads are thing.
It's just the way that we're wired now.
What impact that's going to have on you.
I mean, I don't really know.
I think it's just part of the way we all are.
And you're going to kind of be like monkey
see, monkey do, which to a sense is fine.
I think the real challenge comes when there
are, for example, CDC guidelines and large
populations of people who don't want to follow
them.
Right.
So this is where they're kind of like monkey
see, monkey do brain is telling them, oh,
don't bother wearing a mask when it really
is important because there are new strains.
There are other kinds of considerations to
really think about.
And so I don't really I'm not concerned about
the psychological impact of like switching
whether you wear masks or not is everyone's
going to be equilibria to like what's a what's
a healthy amount of mask wearing?
Speaker 1: Speaking of equilibrium, you mentioned
the significant increase in in depression
and reported depressive symptoms during the
pandemic.
I know many people who have gone on serotonin,
antidepressants, the ones that have been around
for four decades at this point in time.
What is the medical science at this point
about the from what I looked at before our
conversation, it seems like a typical course
of those is often like a 12 to 18 month period.
And then often people start kind of coming
off of those.
Would it be expected that when people get
beyond this phase of the pandemic, where maybe
they don't feel that they need those medications
anymore, that they're going to go sort of
back to their pre pandemic depressive state,
or does this stuff tend to be sort of sticky
and persistent?
Speaker 6: So it's not going to be sticky
and persistent based on my professional experience,
I, I, I'm just going to say that I don't think
that if you have a pandemic induced depression,
I don't know that an SSRI is actually like
an appropriate clinical response.
Interesting.
So so let's remember that depression is a
symptom actually, and has multiple diagnoses
that can lead to depression.
So you can have cancer induced depression,
you can have bipolar disorder, you can have
major depressive disorder, you can have depressive
symptoms relating to trauma.
And what really SSRI is have been studied
very well in is these neurochemical imbalances
really within major depressive disorder.
So I would first of all, personally, I've
been hesitant to just prescribe SSRI to people
who are coming in for the first time depressed
during the pandemic, because we know that
depressive symptoms can be highly circumstantial
and really changing those circumstances is
really the permanent solution.
That being said, so if we kind of assume that
for a second, I wouldn't expect that the gigantic
crop of people who got put on our eyes will
need them going forward.
So I do think it's reasonable to pull off
of medication within I mean, generally speaking,
I'll try within six months to a year interest.
I think 18 months is even sounds a little
bit long to me because the data suggests that
a depressive episode resolves on its own within
one year.
Speaker 1: Basically, I want to talk a little
bit about something that that's maybe a little
more in the political space and whether you
do or don't want to get involved in the political
commentary part is fine.
But we've been seeing what seems to me as
a kind of coping mechanism for those who supported
the former president in the election, essentially
denying that he really lost.
And if we think of denial as maybe the first
stage in a process, sometimes in life, there
seems to be sort of like an inability to move
on from the denial phase that that I'm noticing.
And he's going to be back in August or maybe
it's September and this type of thing is that
what do you make of that?
Do people sometimes never move on from the
denial phase?
Speaker 6: I really can't make much of that,
to be honest, because what I'd really like
to do, David, is like talk to these people
so
Speaker 1: and see what's going on specifically.
Speaker 6: Yeah.
So, I mean, I definitely think that people
can get attached to a particular idea and
they have trouble letting go of that idea.
But I think if we really want to understand
why the denial is so sticky, to use one of
your words, I think the real question is what
does it mean to these people that Trump did
lose and what does it mean to these people
if he comes back?
Because usually what I find in persistent
denial is that it's not the actual thing,
it's what that thing means to the person.
So the world will be a better place.
And I want the world to be a better place
if X, Y or Z happens.
Right.
And so I think it's the association or the
meaning or the interpretation of the particular
event which makes the denial so sticky.
Speaker 1: So maybe asking one of these folks,
like when they call into me it, what would
it mean to you to accept that Trump genuinely
just did lose?
And that might give me insight into why they're
not moving on from the denial.
Speaker 6: Yeah, I would modify that question
a little bit.
I wouldn't say to accept.
What did it mean?
What does it mean to you if Trump lost?
What does it mean to you if he never comes
back?
What would that say about the world?
What would that say?
Because I think what it is, is it's really
the what it says about the world is what they
don't want to accept.
They don't want to live in a world where this
kind of thing happens.
Right.
So they're going to continue hoping that this
is not the world that they live in.
That would be my best guess.
Speaker 1: If you're in your practice, do
you see people who who maybe have a depressive
or an anxiety sort of a situation that is
caused by the sort of general events that
are taking place in society, not the pandemic
is like a very specific medical event, but
sort of like what they identify as a political
problem or something along those lines.
Speaker 6: Absolutely do.
So like this is why, like we started Healthy
Gaymer, because I think what's happening is
depression used to be an isolated neurochemical
imbalance, a malfunction in the brain.
But there's almost like a societal, generational
or existential depression that we see all
throughout, like Gen Z and millennials, to
be honest.
And so, like, the world is just becoming a
bleak place.
And how do people deal with that?
You know, when, when, when?
How can I wake up as a sophomore in college
when I know that every year that goes by,
I'm racking up an insurmountable amount of
debt that as I enter the job market, I'm like
getting into a trench that I'm never going
to escape from.
Right.
How can I get the motivation to study?
And if you go in to see a psychiatrist, they
will check certain boxes diagnosed with depression
and put you on a pill.
And I just don't know that.
I mean, can it help?
Absolutely.
Could there be an underlying neurochemical
malfunction?
Absolutely.
But I think part of the reason that healthy
gamer has grown so much and we basically just
got started right after I was on your show
the last time is because we need different
kinds of solutions in terms of dealing with
these different and new causes of depression
like this.
Existential depression is absolutely real.
Speaker 1: I mean, the student loan thing,
it's almost like a capitalism based depression
of sorts.
Speaker 6: Yeah.
I mean, so I think that this is where, like
something something about the way that our
personal psychology is being affected by world
events seems to be a lot tighter.
So one hundred years ago, I don't know that
world events affected people's psychology
so much.
But as world events get pushed on our mind
so much, they start to have a bigger personal
effect on us.
And that's actually part of the reason that
we started as an organization, because I don't
think the old systems of psychiatry are sufficient
to deal with those kinds of things.
Speaker 1: No question about that.
That part seems that part seems abundantly
clear.
A healthy gamer is the organization we've
been speaking with its co-founder, Dr. Orlock
Kanojia, who's a psychiatrist practicing in
Boston, Massachusetts, and also on the faculty
at Harvard Medical School.
Always great speaking to you.
I appreciate it.
Speaker 6: Thanks a lot, David, as a pleasure
to be back.